from his humble beginnings as a garage
owner and street race bookmaker tej
Parker is now a hacker safe cracker and
full-on secret agent who's driven a
small tank into battle against the
nuclear submarine in other words it's
been a wild ride this is teja's Fast and
Furious backstory explained
when Tesh Parker first appears in two
fast two furious he's the nerve center
of the racing scene in Miami Florida a
former Street racer himself tez retired
from competitive driving after surviving
a high-speed collision and now he
prefers to remain on the sidelines this
has only made him a more important
figure in town by Night tej books the
matchups for quarter mile drag racing
contests on the Miami streets by day
tejos Waterfront jet ski races in either
case tej gets to collect his take from
all the Wagers being made as well as
earn some extra cash by betting on his
favorites outside of his position of
power in the world of illicit street
racing tej also owns a legitimate
business tej's garage where he holds
court with mechanic Jimmy and local
artist racer Sookie during his Reign
Over racing in Miami tej is a young and
boisterous Hustler whose main concern is
making money and he's also a leader with
the respect of his peers on the scene
other Racers follow his rules without
question and when it's time to call in a
favor he has the entire Community behind
him future films in the series will
imply another lie for tej outside of the
scene beyond the years of studying
computer programming that becomes
apparent later on Tash also hints in
fast 5 that he's had prior experience
cracking sophisticated locks
[Music]
when cop turned fugitive Brian O'Connor
arrives in Miami he quickly becomes one
of the stars of the racing circuit tej
sets Brian up with a job at his garage
as well as a bunk aboard one of his
nearby houseboats where Tesh can call on
him to participate in street races on a
moment's notice when Brian and his
childhood friend Roman Pierce get
dragged into an undercover operation for
U.S customs they rely on touch and his
team at the garage to keep their
government issued Mitsubishi evolutions
in order and also to attempt to disable
the GPS tracking devices that the feds
are using to keep an eye on them and
when their mission goes sideways Brian
and Roman need to lose their government
tails in order to defeat drug kingpin
Carter Barone and rescue his hostage
agent Monica Fuentes in a clever effort
to Aid their escape tej organizes dozens
of Street Racers to participate in a
scramble confusing police helicopters
and allowing Brian and Roman to switch
cars dege himself drives off in Brian's
Evo drawing the Authority's attention
and helping Brian and Roman to make a
clear getaway in The Missing Years
between two fast two furious and Fast
Five tej seems to mellow out and begins
to wear his intellect on his sleeve at
some point Des his garage closes down
and his connection to the Miami racing
scene is never mentioned again
Tesh Parker is one of two characters
introduced in 2 Fast 2 Furious who
become regulars in the franchise the
other is Roman pierce the fast talking
x-con performance driver and best friend
of Brian O'Connor
tejan Roman don't interact much in their
first appearance together but by the
time they both return in Fast Five
they've developed a playful rivalry that
evolves over the following films tejan
Roman share a love of cars and a chosen
family but otherwise they seem like
total opposites Roman thinks of himself
as a charmer a Smooth Operator with
endless sex appeal although he
habitually makes a fool out of himself
tej on the other hand has a quiet
confidence backed up by a competence at
nearly everything he attempts Roman is
stingy toward others while tej is
charitable but they both enjoy treating
themselves to the Finer Things despite
getting on each other's nerves tejan
Roman can be found hanging out nearly
anytime that Toretto crew has some
downtime even tejan Roman's mutual
interest in dating Ramsay feels like it
has less to do with her and more to do
with their never-ending contest over
who's cooler in past five years after
their Miami Adventure Brian O'Connor
calls on tej Parker for help once again
Ryan and fellow Precision driver Action
Hero Dominic Toretto are on the lamb in
Rio De Janeiro Brazil where they made an
enemy of local crime Lord Hernan Reyes
hoping both to get even with Reyes and
buy themselves a clean slate Brian Dom
and Mia plan to steal reyes's 100
million dollar fortune in a complex in
darrenheist and I'll need a crack team
of all their most reliable allies to
pull it off Brian brings tej on board as
their circuit man an expert in
electronic software and surveillance
using customized remote control car with
a digital camera mount tej is able to
get a look at the high-end vault in the
Rio police station where Reyes has
Consolidated his cash and he can recall
the detailed specifications of the Vault
from memory however tej has enough safe
cracking experience to know that this
one is basically unbreakable and Friends
Brian and Roman are shocked by his level
of expertise in this area do I want to
know how you know all that I had a life
before you knew me okay let's just leave
it at that time but with help from the
rest of the gang tej requires the
Biometrics he needs to fool the safest
Palm scanner and he takes home roughly
11 million dollars from The Heist not
too shabby
the Rio Heist makes tej a
multi-millionaire but he still enjoys
working for a living tej uses the
windfall to open a new garage tesh's
auto service in the hopes of creating a
place where ordinary folks can get a
fair price on repairs and Fast and
Furious 6 we also learned that tej has
developed a reputation as a modern-day
Robin Hood one that precedes him across
the globe Tesh has no patience for the
stuffy racist posturing of high society
and he's more than willing to leverage
his Newfound wealth to stick it to them
hi there mini offense gentlemen but you
couldn't possibly afford the cars in
this auction
substantial lack of Goldie jewelry no
Entourage no Honeys and Fast and Furious
6 Taj and U.S Diplomatic Security
Service agent Luke Hobbs attended
classic car auction for high rollers and
they're rudely brushed off by a snooty
English salesman tej takes this
opportunity to give the salesman a
dressing down literally first tej
asserts dominance by buying the entire
lot then he exploits the salesman's
sudden polite subservience the demand
that he gave his shirt pants and jacket
to Hops who the suit couldn't possibly
fit tej teaches the salesman a valuable
lesson in humility turning the tables on
someone who assumed he could treat a
stranger like trash to quote another
movie big mistake big huge tej sets out
most of the vehicular action in Too Fast
Too Furious and Fast Five but beginning
with Fast and Furious 6 tej plays a more
Hands-On role in the Toretto Cruise high
octane Adventures for example in Fast
and Furious 6 Tesh participates in the
failed attempt to chase down the
mercenary o and Shaw's indestructible
flip car in London he's also the first
member of the squad to beat defeated
when his BMW is remotely hacked and
disabled leading to a gnarly looking
Crash from this point on tej tends to
favor heavier vehicles in combat
situations tej also continues to use his
mechanical genius to support the crew
such as when he reverse Engineers a
Harpoon Gun used by Shaw's team to give
it increased speed and range this weapon
becomes key to stopping Shaw on The
film's climactic Runaway Chase in which
the Toretto crew attempts to stop Shaw
on his team from escaping Spain in a
massive Antonov cargo jet as the jet
approaches takeoff speed Giselle and
Roman use tej's nos-powered Harpoon guns
to attach cars driven by Han and tej to
the wings of the plane this added way
prevents Shaw from lifting off long
enough for Brian to fire a third Harpoon
through one of the Jet's control flaps
allowing driver Mia Toretto to pull the
plane down and crash it on the runway
over time tej also grows into the team's
cheap strategist in Fast and Furious 6
he coordinates the group's efforts to
stop Owen Shaw from stealing the final
component to the dangerous Nightshade
device from a tank at a Spanish military
base in Furious 7 when the hacker Ramsay
is captured by the terrorist mosasia
Conde it's implied that it's tej's idea
to airdrop the team in Parachute
equipped cars and Ambush her kidnappers
on an otherwise impassable road later
tej devises the plan for stealing the
God's eye Global surveillance program
from the penthouse of etiot towers in
Abu Dhabi coordinating the team's
movements while he hacks the building's
security systems teja's brain is working
overtime throughout Furious 7 but during
the etiod Tower Heist tej also gets a
moment to show off some of his other
muscles when the building's alarms are
triggered he and Ramsey are discovered
in one of the tower's maintenance rooms
by a security guard to everyone's
surprise Tash handily defeats the guard
with a flurry of well-placed punches and
elbow strikes before the Baddie can
alert anyone else to their presence in
other words this dude is equal parts
brain and Brawn during the final
confrontation with mosesia Conde in Los
Angeles tej directs traffic from the
back of Romans Chevrolet Caprice while
the team keeps Ramsay alive long enough
to steal the godside program back from
chicande this is the last of the crew's
major operations in which tej takes a
back seat to anyone
in the fate of the Furious Tesh
continues to play a more active role in
the Toretto Cruise missions first he
rides out with the rest of the team when
they're assigned to collect an EMP
device from a base in Berlin to cover
their escape tez rigs a giant wrecking
ball to swing through their pursuers a
smashing plan that leads to a
spectacular pileup later after Dam goes
Rogue and runs off with the EMP test
drives one of the six cars sent after
him odam is able to outsmart and out
drive his entire team Dom turns out to
be working for the Cyber terrorist
Cipher who has circumvented Ramsay's
God's eye program and made Dom seemingly
impossible to find however tejan Ramsay
are able to out-think cypher and track
him down only to discover the Dom is
already inside their base but why is
their leader gone to the dark side while
Cypher has taken Dom's newborn son
hostage forcing him to run Smash and
grab missions for her in exchange for
the child's life for his supposedly
final task Cipher sends Dom the vladov
in Russia in order to hijack a nuclear
submarine the threatto crew lannis
Toretto himself of course are dispatched
the stop Dom and tej plays a key role in
averting a nuclear catastrophe as he
walks around in the agent known as
little nobody through the process of
disarming the sub finally tej rides into
battle against a confused Russian
regiment in a ripsaw tank rescuing a
drowning Roman along the way
undeniably Tesh Parker has been a loyal
integral part of Dom's crew since he was
enlisted to help with the heist and fast
five through each subsequent Adventure
the characters reinforced his worth
becoming the technical expert in
providing some much needed brain power
by the eighth film of the past Saga he
was one of the primary forces behind
stopping Cipher and Toretto from
enacting their nefarious plants so it
was not surprising to discover Tash
taking on a leadership role by the
beginning of F9 at the start of the
ninth fast film it is tejed assisted by
Ramsay and Roman who tracks down Dominic
Toretto in his retirement Farmhouse to
share news of Cyprus escape with or
without Dom's help tej is set on
answering a distress call from Mr Nobody
and intends to lead a crew into
montequito and would have had toretto's
brother not been involved
quickly reserved for intelligence
missions and reinforcement driving tej
Parker is not typically at the center of
the action understandably the character
has not been a part of any hand-to-hand
combat throughout most of the franchise
that changed in F9 when it was left to
Roman and tej to commandeer a vehicle
operated by an enemy crew and they found
themselves faced with four armed guards
fans did get a sneak peek at teja's
fighting skills in Furious 7 when the
character was quickly able to disarm an
armed guard however in F9 tej and Roman
were significantly outnumbered and had
to perform far more hand-to-hand combat
skills than they ever have before thanks
to some impromptu driving from Ramsay
the pair were able to come out on top
next to their Victory the crew gained a
new weapon magnets the fast Saga has
continuously outdone itself with new
tricks and action sequences and F9 took
things to another level thanks to teja's
Ingenuity the magnets became an integral
part of their mission moving forward
first the magnets assist the crew in
making a hasty getaway when their
Hideout is infiltrated by Jacob Toretto
and his team later the magnets helped to
cause mechanical Mayhem as Dom and his
team utilize them to draw into repel
cars during a climactic racing while
experts have dispelled the myth that any
of these movie stunts would be possible
and that magnets are simply not that
strong it doesn't change the fact that
it's pretty cool
when audiences first met tej in 2003's
Too Fast Too Furious they could never
have imagined how high he would fly
admitting in his first appearance that
he was retired from driving it was
already a shock when tej became a part
of Dom's crew in Fast Five and in F9 the
character pulled off the most elaborate
stunt of any character in the franchise
lifting into the stratosphere to fly a
car in space tej's rocket-powered
Pontiac Fiero is a result of Ingenuity
from near forgotten franchise player
Sean Twinkie and Earl from Tokyo Drift
although their test run did not go quite
as planned a second attempt to managed
to get tej and his longtime wingman
Roman out of Earth's atmosphere by the
end of F9 Tesh Parker found himself in
Dom's backyard once again enjoying
barbecue and preparing for his next
insane mission
knowledge